chile será el primer país de américa
latina en inocular la cuarta dosis
cuenta con más del 85% de la población
con dos inyecciones mientras que el 57%
ya tiene tres inoculaciones desde el 10
de enero los inmunodeprimidos podrán
acceder a la cuarta dosis así lo anunció
el presidente sebastián piñera
experiencia nos ha mostrado que la
eficacia de las vacunas y también de los
refuerzos
disminuye con el tiempo y también con la
aparición de nuevas variantes
como omicron que ya afecta con fuerza
todo el continente especialmente a
argentina donde este jueves se registró
récord de contagios con más de 100.000
en 24 horas una tendencia que también
sigue colombia donde se registraron más
de 23.000 casos un día después de que el
gobierno advirtiese de que se podría
llegar a los 40 mil casos diarios aunque
los expertos avisan de que se está
produciendo un subregistro
y aunque según estudios omicron podría
ser menos letal brasilia cuenta con su
primera muerte por la variante un hombre
de 68 años con tres dosis y morbilidad
es falleció en aparecida de goiánia en
goiás cuando la variante ya es
responsable del 90 y 3.5 por ciento de
los casos en perú país con mayor tasa de
huérfanos por kobe del mundo el gobierno
de pedro castillo reimpulso toques de
queda en lima y en otras 24 provincias
del país entre las 11 de la noche y las
4 de la mañana un incremento de casos
muy rápido y sustancial en particular en
liba pero también a nivel nacional lo
cual confirma el inicio de una tercera
ola unos apuestan por restricciones y
cubas sigue apostando por la vacunación
masiva espera administrar la tercera
dosis a toda su población en enero
mientras este jueves ha enviado un
millón de vacunas soberana 2 para niños
a nicaragua